oh mein gott heute wasser diesem video
hier passieren wir wissen ich
wahrscheinlich teil davon euch selbst in
den kühnsten träumen ausmalen können
meine lieben zuschauer ich bin guter
anfang
ich weiß das ist noch nie vorgekommen
wie er spielt nämlich heute zusammen
broll stars das ist ein spiel fürs handy
und ich bin dort tatsächlich relativ gut
drin machen und alle leute die selber
polster spielen
das hier sind meine brüder auf dem us-
markt aber im endeffekt dieses video
hier ist übrigens nicht gesponsert oder
wir kein geld für das spiel spielt das
ist nur einfach echt geiles game in
diesem spiel gibt es verschiedene
minispiele und den modus sehe ich jetzt
gerade spieler haben das ist quasi jeder
gegen jeden
also ich muss den töten und auf den
töten ich stimme nicht mit dir degas ich
bin sehr gut in dieses spiel
jetzt habe ich einfach mal hier in den
anderen browser ausgewählt der
highschool
er hat zwei waffen und er kann auf
längere ja kommen haben wir die kiste
liga alles gute ja es kommt natürlich
dich jetzt aber dafür mag was ich sagen
wollte ist dass es in diesem modus darum
geht die leute das ist übrigens eine
multi also ich kann kraft durch alles
durch schießen dann a2 kills in diesem
modus geht es darum dass jeder gegen
jeden spielt also ich muss eigentlich am
ende der einzige überlebende bleiben und
in diesen gebüschen ihr seht ihr schon
dass es dann so ein bisschen anders als
wenn ich hier bin
da kann ich mich darin verstecken wenn
er will die schwester hinten hier kommt
[Musik]
jetzt hört man noch den spike dahinten
hier da läufst du hin los hier hin genau
zu actano mein gott
ok ok klicken
ja geil alter freude ist dieser kleine
penner hier stößt du gift strahlen auf
mit dem gift strahlen dann kriegt man
nie ganz
ich schwöre ich bin gut die haben wir
jetzt treibholz auf einem haufen das
heißt ich werde mir erst mal den nach
vorne können hier sollte erst mal wenn
ich mir die kiste von dem ja genau das
ist jetzt natürlich bisschen sie gewesen
das ist übrigens das zeichen dafür dass
einer mit einem team in will das sehe
ich ein bisschen scheiße dieser ganze
modus hier ist halt voll mit tiemann und
dann bist du nachher halt irgendwie mit
der einzige der noch am leben
warum hatten nicht töten dicker es ist
ein ernst danke du bist jetzt auch noch
tot perfekt dankeschön also wenn ich
jetzt zu ihm ihr dahin laufen würde und
so machen würde dann wird er
wahrscheinlich ja genau jetzt sind wir
ein team chieming ist scheiße und das
ist nicht der grund warum diese spiele
gemacht warum mein gott das hier ist
bull
der ist relativ gut im nahkampf ich will
nicht mit dem team
hahaha also jetzt so ja bei den sieg die
ist auch noch weg
ja kann ich mal tot warum kann ich
einmal gefilden showdown ist der modus
sehen wir gerade gespielt haben da
kämpft jeder gegen jeden
dann gibt es noch den hier da muss man
zehn diamanten holen die kämpfe im team
gegeneinander
diese beiden leute hier sind meine
anderen teamkameraden schießt du mich
denn ab dh sie sind in einem team das
hier sind diese diamanten die man sich
holen muss das war meine ultima also ich
feiere einfach ein bisschen stärker wir
halten gerade 0 diamanten und der gegner
9 also wir sind darauf zu verlieren und
wir haben verloren in diesem modus geht
es darum dass wir ein tresor haben und
den müssen wir schützen und den von dem
gegner müssen wir zerstören da finde ich
diesen bull charakter den ich mir gerade
habe eigentlich ganz gut
der schießt halt relativ wenig also
wenig weit darf aber relativ viel
schaden und das ist bei dieser map
das ist doch einmal leben besitzen dass
sie alter die sind bürger aus dem tresor
ich schwöre ich kann dieses spiel bei
dem seed modus geht es darum dass man
über einen längeren zeitraum schrauben
sammelt und der der mehr schrauben hat
der baut sich damit ein roboter zusammen
der roboter attackierte an den
gegnerischen tresor der modus ist ein
bisschen schwer zu verstehen aber das
hier sind auf jeden fall die schrauben
die wir uns holen müssen kein alter dass
sie jetzt live act 10.000 alter das ding
geht jetzt auf unser tor eine ahnung
wann die scheiße fixen werden ich mag
das spiel halt weil es nicht komplett
pagewizz und ich bin halt auch einfach
sehr süchtig danach ich habe keine
ahnung ob wir dieses spiel überhaupt
kennt das hier ist übrigens die person
mit der ich gerade spiele also das ist
so ein typ der wirft feuerbälle rum und
dann brennen diese davor und ja der ist
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so gut
ich bin schon nice alter david sechs
schrauben gesammelt haben ist das hier
jetzt unser level 6 roboter mit dem
gehen wir jetzt auf den tresor nach
hinten greifen denen an und jetzt ist
unser sport schrott das heißt wir
vermissen und wieder ja kommt egal wir
haben schon wieder neuen schrauben und
der gegner nur vier also dass sie
tatsächlich wahr nachdem sie kia aus
dass man so ab auf den privaten
vielleicht schaffen dass er jetzt schon
ich bin gut dass die runde von sonder
event findet nur alle paar tage statt
dafür braucht man halt eintrittskarten
um damit zu spielen weil die belohnungen
da halt relativ hoch sind allerdings
spielen wir jetzt mal diesen jeder gegen
jeden modus
jetzt wird rasiert ich weiß nicht ob ich
dieses spiel möglichst viele überhaupt
kennt weil ich glaube dass viele von
meinen zuschauer noch gar nicht so
richtig gaming affin sind
ich habe nur gesehen dass auf youtube
tatsächlich doch viele leute bloß da
spiele ich dachte mir hey ich spiele
jetzt auch nur halt immer ja wenn ich
nicht auf youtube von daher dachte ich
ich lass mal hoch auf einem kanal ein
mensch gefällt könnt ihr gerne daumen
hoch da lassen kann doch kein abonnieren
falls ihr mich nicht allzu beschlüssen
findet und wir warten jetzt erstmal bei
wir sind in der mitte von der mep die
zone wird übrigens auch mal klein also
wie bei ford als das heißt die zone ist
am ende hier genau in der mitte und
dementsprechend müssen alle gegner auch
er zu uns kommen als dass wir zudem
kommen müssen diese teile die ich da mit
meinem kopf stehen haben sind bei jd
power punkte
also wenn ich das ding jetzt einsammeln
dann seht ihr schon geht die zahl auf
sechs mein leben geht ein bisschen hoch
und ich mache halt mehr schaden also je
mehr anteilig von denen habe desto
stärker bin ich damit wollen dagegen
vorgehen dass wir die leute nur kempen
dass sie dann nachher genau so stark
sind wir einer der voll viele leute
tötet erstes die ultimative super kanal
und genauer als ich bin jetzt auf jeden
fall unsichtbar und es liebt
noch 4 3
okay das habe ich immer in hamburg
jetzt erwartet er dass es noch mal an
das heißt vom alter war so gut wir
spielen doch mal was ich sagen wollte
ist dass sich auf youtube mein gott sie
ist eine ganz komische und zwar macht
sie mehr schaden je weiter sie von einem
weg der sorge gottes gesehen
okay okay ich bin schon weg die java
meiner mitte da sind auch schon leute
das heißt ich bin jetzt relativ arm dran
ich habe kein einziges power dings und
ich bin hässlich und das auch noch und
daher werde ich jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen kämpfen und mich eine spannt
zurücklehnen
so und jetzt holt mich auch schon fast
die zone 1 das heißt ich gehe jetzt
erstmal auf ihnen hier drauf und mein
gott ich war hinter den schrank gefallen
ja dann ist in den nächsten video zeit
nicht mehr
das liegt daran dass man zu diesem modus
hier aussagen muss es auch mein gott
schon wieder so eine meint doch dein
eigenes business alter macht das was
hier wollte jetzt dass euer vater ernst
was man bei diesem modus ja auch noch
sagen muss dass man nicht nur punkte
kriegt wenn man erster wird sondern
sobald man besser ist als der sechste
platz bekommt man eigentlich pluspunkte
können wir uns mal hierhin noch schön
die kühlste wie macht das spiel
eigentlich echt ziemlich viel spaß es
ist halt nicht so wie bei clash of
clarence dass man warten muss bis man
dann irgendwann weiter spielen kann oder
bei clash royal dass es halt so voll
krass ey twin ist sondern das ist echt
eigentlich in kunduz ausgeglichenes
spiel neu sind hier viele kisten
alternativ wird eine gute runde freunde
ich habe zehn power level und werde das
ding jetzt nach hause holen
und das hat mich sehr stolz gemacht den
tüten bei der hat sogar gezielt mit
dieser anderen ich gebe auf den leon
hier unten erst mal so dann haben wir
den hier ich habe 16 stück er hat einen
ja komm mach dein ding danke da mal
wieder ein winter holt aber kommt einer
geht noch
was sind denn das für gauner alter jeder
spieler hat sein vorgefertigten krieg
mit seinen kids day out
das erst wieder abgefallen man leute
macht euren eigenen scheiß man ja kommt
von allen seiten geil alter als sofa ist
ja und jetzt freunde die ich taktisch
vor das heißt ich stehe im busch mache
mich jetzt hier unsichtbar das heißt
keiner sieht so richtig dass sie mich
unsichtbar gemacht habe und der typ
denkt hier ist keine überrascht so den
haben wir auch noch zunächst einmal hole
ich mir dich hier so zac und jetzt
schaut hingegen sieht das ding jetzt
ihre fähigkeit ist es halt dass sie sich
für kurze zeit ja das hat ziemlich dumm
dass sich das jetzt eingesetzt hat dann
bekommt sie halt viel viel viel viel
weniger schaden wenn man sie trifft aber
jetzt habe ich eine ganz gute chancen
[Musik]
mal schauen wie viel wie heute
wow an der stelle wird das heutige video
endlich auch beendet meine lieben
freunde ich spiele in letzter zeit sehr
viel brot darf sich makler spiel einfach
unglaublich gern hab jetzt gesehen dass
in deutschland noch einige youtuber das
hochladen und dachte dann hey spielt
auch aber bin dumm gucken wenn euch
heute dennoch mal wieder hier in gaming
video auf seinem kanal gefallen hat dann
das gerne einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video abonniert main kanal falls sie
noch kein technokrat und falls sie schon
aber nennt sein klicken auf die glocke
dann bekommt ihr instant eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video
[Musik]